it's one of the issues that i'm familiar
with so a woman can have a penis
i'm not but
i don't think we can conduct this
debate with
you know
hey kkk do you think politicians talk
too much yes i wish there was a way to
shut them up there is jk rowling's
latest book what's a woman and other
impossible questions follow her simple
instructions to turn any politician into
this because
some
people out there in our nation don't
have maps and i believe that our
education like such as south africa and
iraq everywhere like such as it's not
just politicians either supreme court
nominee katanji brown jackson had some
issues with this as well
uh can you provide a definition for the
word woman can i provide a definition no
yeah
i can't you can't
not okay this context
now i'm not a proctologist but even i
know she's talking out of her ass how
can you not know the difference between
men and women i actually think it's very
progressive i wish both my parents happy
mother's day how did that go my dad was
russian so he disowned me now i'll never
inherit the ladder boris had no problem
answering this question that's because
boris has seen more vaginas than a
burnout gynecologist what a nightmare
for doctors giving a woman a prostate
exam must be quietly experienced now
they got it covered
we joke about this but it's gonna hurt a
lot of people people like us
yeah what am i meant to do when i'm
driving my white van and i see a top
bird birthing person and i want to
compliment her on our massive chest
feeders and i want her to get them out
for the lads well that's fine just don't
misgender anyone
oy person i don't know how you identify
but i'd love to do you up the stick
[Music]
bye